バン!!バン!!
バンバンバババババババババババン!!
バァァァァン!!!!
.........
こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。
僕ネットでよく買い物をするんですよ
ネットでよく買い物をするんですけども
あのよくね...
あれ！？これ頼んだっけ？
これ頼んだ覚えがないよ！
っていうのがたまにあるんですよ
で今回まさにそれの典型的な例で
全く身に覚えが無い
全く身に覚えはないんですけども
なんかうっすら記憶にあるんだみたいなのが
届きました
で気になっちゃって
分かんなかったからもうちょっと
開けちゃいました
うん合ってるな
完全に俺が頼んでるんですけど
海外から来てるんですよ
あ、でもなんか完全に
海外から来てるこれは
いや、でもこれね多分ね
絶対にね俺はね面白いと思って
買ってたんだと思うよ
はい、モールダブルグルー
僕なんかよく見てるんですよね
面白い物はねぇかなって
すごい髪の毛が抜けるぞ今日
僕しょーもない物が大好きなんですよ
ハンドスピナーとか何気なく買ったし
なんかよく分かんないけど
目の出るアザラシも買いました
結構意味不明な物が好きなんで
多分そのたぐいだと思われます
開けてみましょう
マジこれ、身に覚えがない買い物っていうのが
一番怖いからな
( ﾟдﾟ)
(´-ω・)ﾝ?
なんか使い方の本が書いてあります
おーなんか家中の色んな物に使えるよ
みたいな
やかんのなんかこういう持ち手にも使えんの
おもちゃが取れた時にも使えるみたいな
なになんかいろんなことに使えるみたいですね
粘土みたいなやつみたいなんですけども
ケーブルが壊れそうな時に守れたりする
的な？
英語で書いてあります
クジオン･･･
キュージョン
まぁ･･･
とりあえず
開けます！
こういうの何はともあれ
使ってみるのが一番いい気がするんだよね
たぶんネットで変な動画見たんですよ
海外の
その動画見る限りなんか凄い
いろんなことに使えてた的な？
開けます
うわあああ！
びっくりした
のりくん！！！！
ああこんな感じか
うわあなんか
こんな感じでーす
何なんだろうね
たぶんね これ
みたいな
確かネットで見たやつだと
スマホの裏につけて
こういうとこに貼ると
くっつくみたいな！
ほら！
くっつくんですよ！
結構重いけどくっついてます
このたったこれだけの形で
例えばですよ
を回して
この裏にこれを付けて
これをスマホの裏に付けたら
完全に･･･わっちゃあああ！！！
これ完全に扇風機ですからね
あ、多分そうそうそうなんだよ
なんかめっちゃ強い…
こっちだ
めっちゃ強いんですよ
ベットで寝ながらテレビとかYoutubeとか見ることができるってわけでございます
実際すごくないですか
やばい電話が来た
こういうね電話がきてもね
ここからでれるんですよ
もしもし
はーい分かりました
はーいじゃあねー
はーい
って具合にですね
さすがにこの大きさだと限界はあるもののなんでもくっつきます
えっこれまって何かやばいな分かんないわ
何、何か俺使い方間違ってたのかな
要するにこれは何か粘土の形をした接着剤的な奴らしいです
だから何か使い方は無限大らしいですね
だから形を決めると24時間でそれで固まっちゃうらしい…です
何かすごい。なん…何でもくっつけれる気がするな
ちょっといろいろこれを使ってくっつけてみましょう
今からいろんなものをちょっとくっつけてみるので
どれくらいの重さまで耐えれるのか。
ちょっといろいろ貼り付けて検証してみたいと…うわああああああ
大失敗やないかい！
今のは不慮の事故です
いろいろちょっと貼っ付けてみようと思います
まあ現状この状態だとどれくらいかなと確かめていきまっしょう
あーなんかもうここまでくっつくなら結構なんでもくっつく気がしますね
全然ダメじゃん
なんでだー？
くっつくのとつかないのがある
分かったことが1つある
たぶん共通しているのはついてる残りの3つは全部硬いです
ティッシュの箱とか雑誌は柔らかいのでひょっとしたら柔らかいやつにはくっつきにくいのかもしれません
i Pad pro わんちゃん
i Pad pro がついたら本物ですよ
あっあっあっあっあっついたついたついた
i Pad pro ついた
あーもうこれしかないっしょ
もうこれがついたら本物です
デュワァァァァァァン（効果音）
いやぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ!!!!!!!!!
どぅわああああああああああい！！！！
い”や”あああああ